allison felix joins us now welcome
congratulations and what was that
reunion like with your daughter
thank you so much oh my gosh it was so
amazing i had that was the longest i had
ever been away from my daughter so it
was such a sweet moment to be reunited
you know kids have this way of bringing
us into reality in a different way than
anyone else can and i'm thinking you
come home the most decorated track and
field olympian of all time for the u.s
did you have a moment though with for
your daughter that it's just mommies
there and i need a mommy thing
absolutely right away actually it hit me
my daughter was at school i got a call
she was sick and so it was right right
back into mommy mode taking care of her
but you would be the fastest mom to pick
up their daughter at school as her i
always think of that t-shirt no problem
getting there right you know allison
yeah for sure there are a lot of um
women moms who have been olympians that
i've spoken with and they've talked
about this idea that after childbirth
your body just changes and your body is
your temple as an athlete give us a
sense of what this olympics was like for
you in the training and then obviously
in what you were able to do
while being a mom and having all those
changes that you had to go through
yeah it was definitely so different you
know i experienced all those things that
you know other women talk about and it
was a very humbling experience and it
took me quite a bit of time to be able
to get back to top form and so for me
this olympics was so much different
because when i was younger it was so
much about you know the medals and
winning and the performance and it still
was but i also wanted to represent for
other mothers you know and show them
that you can overcome adversity that you
can get back to your best self and still
have your best performances you know
after giving birth
you did and you you also again the most
decorated track and field olympian for
the u.s passing carl lewis has that
sunken in yet
i don't think it has completely i mean
it's just an honor to even be mentioned
in the same breath as him um endless
inspiration for me but i'm just happy
you know with my experience you know
through the years and being able to take
part you know in in the games
allison uh another reason why we're
having you on this morning not only is
uh that you came back from tokyo that
you're the winningest olympian of all
time all of that but there's an amazing
organization uh or or advocacy effort
that you are uh partnering with
bridgestone on it's called the chasing
the dream grant what can you tell us
about it
yeah i'm really proud to be a team
bridgestone athlete and bridgestone is
donating 125 thousand dollars to
adaptive sports and so this is to help
with access
training equipment and local programs
and it's really in the spirit of the
paralympic games and so i'm so excited
that they're making this investment and
also hopefully people will be excited to
watch these athletes i know i'm so
looking forward to tuning in and to
cheering them on because they are
amazing inspirations
and this is going to be great for them
yeah
allison after so many years of having to
be in absolutely peak physical condition
to compete i know you can get out of
shape in a week and it can take months
to get back into shape it can feel
really good to get out of shape as you
glide into whatever's next for you are
you going to be sitting on the couch a
little more
i'm definitely eating a lot of my
favorite foods you know when i got
welcomed home by my family they were
like what is the one thing that you want
and it was the food that i missed the
most so i had some catfish i had some
red beans and rice so i'm definitely you
know already enjoying all of that
well enjoy the time with your daughter
too and your family we know you missed
having her there and thank you for the
inspiration that you are thanks for
being with us
you're watching
thank you for having me you're welcome